game you got a sellout alert on that
stay trashy tour look out we're adding
shows we're selling out shows we're
adding City bring the squad it's a good
time Gang mix of stand-up comedy and of
course you play the language with the
crowd come out and see us yeah the big
man ain't lying starting in March we're
going to be in Baltimore Virginia Beach
Richmond Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas all right Austin Texas
sold out second show out and get those
tickets get those ticks then in April
New Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont
then in May we're going to Tampa Florida
that sold out we added another one let's
go now we're going to Dania Beach
Florida then we're going to Raleigh
North Carolina then in may we had a
Louisville Kentucky get those tickets
and then in June we have Cleveland and
Columbus guys tickets are moving don't
snooze on it let's party we'll see you
there see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now you here are your
hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that they're going to be
classy yeah just a big old piece of
trash trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here in Aunt Cody's basement little
update on tutty oh no she wasn't feeling
good last week I heard right she'd gone
in for a little procedure the week
before uh-huh turns out they left
something in her oh boy sunglasses
anesthesiologist left to pair of
sunglasses Ray-Bans must have fell off
the top of the [__] big ones the
novelty ones
they left them in there uh-oh they took
them out she's feeling better she's on
the men's okay they're talking about
trying to keep it quiet so I don't want
to say what hospital she was sure all
right but there might be a little bit of
a Payday coming our way uh-oh and she's
said if it all works out the way she
wants it to she might throw an addition
on the back of the house on hoodies
maybe make a little room for the boys
out there that's what she's saying who
knows now she's doing she was probably
searching for perks if you ask me she's
throwing a lot of pain pills so she's
making a lot of promises I'm sure she
also told me that she's gonna start
dating Alex Trebek
Mark Carlos is coming at you from across
the table this is a family episode he is
the CEO of are you garbage he is an
international businessman and I'll tell
you what right now I don't care who
knows it my best pal in the whole wide
world give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
hey what's up gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on iTunes full video of
album YouTube as you know those numbers
are
rocketing baby [__] well over 115 000
over there on YouTube uh and then
obviously I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention mod I don't want to speak for
the group or for my family my favorite
website sure is
www.pornhub.com he's going to say XNXX
is probably still my number patreon.com
garbage baby where the rubber hits the
road the bread gets buttered good times
nine yards we have a bajillion two
bajillion hours of content you heard it
here first got hard feelings you got the
Disney vids you got everything both
Disney vids are up Epcot of us drinking
around the world that just dropped about
two three days ago us getting sloshed
over there and it looks like I don't
want to predict anything we're on our
way to Indianapolis for the Indy five I
mean that's happening anyway yeah I
already got the tickets I gotta go
hey either we're gonna film it or not
I'm going well we're real close to
hitting that goal we can't thank you
enough and we love you to death and we
appreciate you and speaking of
appreciating having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones and twos crosses the D's dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody what
up Duds how you feeling pal I'm great
that was a real nice intro do you owe me
money
no it's not it's not what he texted me
yesterday by the way piece of [__] now I
love you buddy love you too here for a
family episode Kip what's cooking oh man
that means H Foley's got zilk this
sometimes sometimes red I got I heard
you just got back from Puerto Rico oh
man they still speak Spanish down there
what's going on
man I hear you're getting older what
you know what I saw in Hawaii that uh
that made me think it's it's pretty
trashy which I never put it together if
you got a t-shirt with the Skeleton on
it oh yeah that's bad that or like the
boot like the better body like the
six-pack or whatever unless it's right
near Halloween rocking the skeleton
black tea is a real tough that's a tough
look I got so there's a little more hard
feelings-esque but it was one of those
it was one of those moments I'm at the
I'm at the pool ball not the pool bar
like yeah the outdoor pool bar not the
swim up pool bar which are they they're
trashy right yeah everyone's peeing in
there I love them ah man you get me a
good pool bar dude if there's if there's
a stool underwater too sometimes they
have that sure he's posted up like
Aquaman
[__] doing underwater beers kid
sitting there chatting up a clown fish
uh I'm big on uh really
really more like an orca
I'm big on personal space right I like
my personal space
uh and sometimes you know when you're
mixing with these different characters
that you meet at a resort or whatever
this guy I'm at the pool bar enjoying my
time I got the birds at the spa game I
gotta be real drunk to talk to strangers
oh I didn't talk to him I did a little
bit in a hot tub I was chatting off
where are you chatting up chatting up a
nice family from DC
hey is this serious
hey what's her name these are kids in
the hot tub no I don't think kids should
be allowed in a hot tub too sexy nah
it's just what are we doing that's an
adult environment of course get out of
here sure you don't see me in the kiddie
pool unless I'm real drunk unless I
can't find a bathroom you know what I
mean jump in there for two seconds and
hop out
um so uh I'm at the pool bar I'm hanging
out having a couple of surveys as you
will sure a couple of Coronas or
whatever there you go and um guy next to
me gets right out of the pool right like
from underwater out of the pool doesn't
grab a towel doesn't blot off doesn't do
nothing comes over to me now he's like
he choose he could have went a little
further but he's like right on my
sidearm to the point where his wet arm
is touching my arm wait where are you
I'm at the pool bar like at the bar
outside like Mexico
all right and he comes up so he's like
getting my arms like wet so I'm like ah
come on you know I just kind of like
shift a little bit dude and then the
grossest thing that ever has happened to
me in my whole entire life he was like
yeah can I get you know whatever two of
these one of these and a margarita and
the guy goes yeah where are you sitting
like I'll send it over and he goes he
has long hair and he goes right over
there and turned his head and his
ponytail turned into like a water gun
and dude all in my mouth dude just I
could still feel it on my lips it was
taste his condition
first and foremost I thought it was Toby
for a second look like a wet rat this
[__] guy by the way there's something
somebody posted that picture of you as a
little kid on the uh your dad it was his
dad oh really oh yeah first of all your
dad looked like he could [__] he looked
mess somebody up he looked Jack Jack
he's like this is Toby's first roller
coaster ride I'm like is that I'm like
that kind of looks like him if your dad
was on HGH
yeah and dude the most adorable kid I
ever seen in my life a little redhead
look at you yeah it was a cute kid
freaking out
yeah we got that picture framed in my
house there you go that's pretty the
roller coaster the two kids behind you
are perfectly uh early 2000s oh they're
like goofing off it like fake fighting
each other I never did that oh I thought
I'd be testing my luck getting too cocky
to try something for the camera I'll
tell you that's how your [__] head
gets there ends up on the local news I'm
not doing that all they found was his
keys that was me on Space Mountain with
that GoPro I was able to lose my [__]
arm Jesus Christ ah the the the roller
coaster photo is pretty trashy we my mom
never sprung for it that was a rip-off
no we never did should we get somebody
to take it from like it sneak in and get
down there that was it painful they they
jammed me up at like Disney or I don't
know if Disney but like places if you go
on try to take a picture of it they got
no pictures no pictures they like jump
in there because they want there they
want their that's a dying market right
there you know what I mean I mean we
have full video on the thing who needs
sure a static shot you know what I mean
yeah I got a three camera shoot going on
the log flume that and the um that
reminded me when our boots
all right that reminded me of um did you
have any a fake uh Sports covers as a
kid what's a sports cover like a cover
of like Sports Illustrated like a
Wheaties box or whatever yeah maybe in
like t-ball like very young uh I thought
I was gonna get drafted by the Yankees
that supports the fake Sports
Illustrated that was like an extra five
bucks one year my mom sprung for it man
I use that to try to buy beer
sitting there ready to roll 30 of ID I'm
on the cover of All-Star magazines
it was Slugger quarterly or something
dude that was that was that was a very
humbling year because I had that done we
had this big picture today shout out to
Whit Payne Township used to [__] they
used to really put on a nice uh picture
day and started the baseball season they
get baseball cards sure they would have
made up my uncle yeah all right uncle
was the company rookie rookie year H
Foley's floating around out there
there's a couple but here's what he did
he put on the back utility player
my own Uncle I remember I had he knew
you weren't a star I had to go home and
ask my dad I'm like what's a utility
player
that's six man
most improved I would have rather had
right field yeah her manager or
something equipment guy something
utility player
he's just got all the snacks that you
eat as your stats
14 orange slices two cans of Coke and a
chili dog kennel crushed through a pack
of sunflower seeds it's our garbage time
kid dude brutal yeah that's tough I
remember one time I was getting my
picture taken I probably I was young
t-ball asked maybe right like maybe
because what did it go for you on t-ball
for us
coach pitch coach kid pitch yeah that's
how we did it and I tell you what in the
80s those dads used to put a little
pepper on the ball a little mustard on
it a little stink they didn't care I
remember my my dad I think it was my dad
was thrown to me and I'm like give me a
couple [__] how about a grapefruit
give me a couple of Hoagies right down
the plane what the [__] is it what are
you throwing knuckle balls left he's
throwing at you that's my play Gippy
give me a [__] you know give me a
school bus coming right down to center
lane here he was taking [__] out on me I
remember I don't know if it was him or
so I remember someone I remember being
like buddy [__] kitten this is this is a
friendly game here I remember I lost the
championship for our team
um it was little league in Wilkes-Barre
uh shout out to the North End Little
League Association it was pretty top
shelf we had like an awesome we had like
an actual uh field that had like a fence
and everything we had the snack bar we
had the umps we had the kids announcing
up there we were playing on a dead end
well the one that a second when we moved
to wit pain it wasn't it wasn't that it
wasn't that locked in it was like this
was like a like a baseball field it was
nice
but uh I understand I understand what
you're putting down here big guy I had
just moved up from whatever whatever you
know I don't know six and under to I was
the youngest of the group so I was like
let's say
ten through eight or something like that
and I was eight and we were playing in
the championship game and somehow it
came down to me
two outs kid on the mound I launched it
yeah brutal that's tough kids did not
hold back at their disappointment really
oh even my brother was making fun of me
you blew it this and that and the other
you call yourself but you never had the
makings of a varsity athlete
yeah I remember I was I remember
standing for uh
uh the pictures right uh-huh and uh made
me take my shirt off I never took a good
one of those no I've had my I was hold I
guess I was holding the I whatever I was
bad upside down I was holding it wrong I
had it on my wrong shoulders I remember
being like sick and the guy being like
what's this kid's deal or whatever
that was like buddy real utility
breaking my Stones here how am I gonna
get on the cover of this [__]
All-Star magazine yeah and I remember he
was like are you right-handed or
left-handed I'm like I don't know dude
you're holding the tennis racket I just
[__] my pants
[__] you mean dude I can't even read
dude yeah take this frisbee go out to
the parking lot
man I was always jealous of the kids
that like look good in those pictures
and like the stuff fit right none of
that stuff ever fit me right the Hat was
always goofy yeah yeah tough look I feel
like your pants would have been
different colors from your shirt kid
playing in sweatpants yeah yeah I don't
think I fit them in the traditional
sense
he [__] them in the traditional sense
yeah
yeah I had like grown men stirrups on
they went up to like my nuts yeah it was
not a good look yeah it's a tough I I
mean I I remember being so lost in like
tea as like a five or like very young
you know what I mean where you're like
just kind of go up and whatever and
being like I don't know what's going on
you're running the third nor do I
[__] care man this [__] stinks back
to play my video games or something what
the [__] puppy smoke from the other side
what are you doing what do you do during
the day
I got good bunnies I want to talk shot
with some real men you know what I mean
picking up side work huh you're not
[__] doing this [__] [__]
tiddlywinks over here I'll say this
though I know uh cooler technology has
gotten better but do you remember those
Igloo jugs of water that had the little
thing on top and they were like metal on
the inside metal on the inside yeah dude
this thing would put out you could taste
the field on it a little bit in the
water you know what I mean I don't know
why I said it like that but man those
things would produce screaming cold
water in the seventh inning yeah all
right I don't even
I remember the first time we got into
kid pitch this kid was throwing smoke
and I was like there's I was struggling
with the tea buddy what the [__] are we
doing here hey you got [__] you know
the only kid to strike out in t-ball
the last time I played kid pitch the
other kid hit a week ago
that blue team was pretty good
the kid hit so many players on our team
that we had to Forfeit
really yeah dude smash me in my elbow it
sucked ass quick my son's a [__]
is there a doctor here
the elbow
oh man they're prepping you for surgery
wow yikes but this is a family episode
gang we're here to answer your garbage
questions oh yeah yeah when you as you
know when you join the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
it's just the best way to do it and
cause that patreon's a gosh don't party
over there I said that a million times
you know good time uh this one's from
Noah Banks ten dollar homie never have
one red shout out to it is it garbage to
drive barefoot I like to feel the engine
through my toes it's so funny you
mentioned that I respect it it's trashy
though I love it too I do it it's
illegal I believe it might be yeah yeah
because I think you can miss and catch a
toe on the brake or the gas it's your
shoe can slip behind the brake so then
you can't stop
what that's why it's illegal that would
mean it'd be illegal to take my shoes
off while I'm driving I in the summer
I'll get in the car without shoes on I
think it's just the heat don't want you
to have a good time because it's all
right thanks a lot Bin Laden take that
from me too I thought this country was
based on freedom it's all based on the
Patriot Act
no partying if you can read your text
and you're not on a drive with you yeah
it's illegal to drive barefoot I think
but it is it is fun I think I've
mentioned before I remember a girl in
Kai was probably in college
freshman year or whatever it was a
summer like one of those Summers you're
like back home and this girl would drive
topless really oh wait wait my buddy was
seeing her wait a minute wait a minute
what and at night she would drive
topless wait why Wow I followed her for
about 40 miles
trying to get in front of her
trying to cause you almost rear-ended
her
she would drive topless just let the
girls out I don't know I mean you know
you gotta
yeah you like to do stuff topless even
even in my best shape I never drove with
a shirt off you had to be ripped to pull
that off I don't even shower with my
shirt what are you talking about they're
in a winter coat uh wow really huh it's
not illegal what it's totally legal to
drive without shoes my dad told me it
was illegal my whole life yeah it's a
common misconception there you go really
yeah that's it shoes off everything okay
partying driving with my big toe
there is something I like you I split my
toes on the pedals you know what I mean
like I don't use my whole foot sometimes
I'll just use my big toe sure you feel
real power yeah it feels good back to
the topless broad sure I never saw her
again she was around I don't he like
wait would she do it when other people
were in the car other girls I remember
we were driving home from the pub one
night uh-huh and we pulled up next to
them
and he's like I my buy was with my buddy
and she was with her I forget
and he goes I bet you she's topless and
we pulled up sure is you know I wish I
was in a [__] semi truck so I gotta
like
so I had a vantage point from up top
where was it good I was in a lowered
Civic so where's the GoPro when you need
one huh
no kidding yeah that's pretty spicy
uh-huh I used to think it was real sexy
when uh girls would drive with their
knee sure I always loved that he just
wasn't going to high school you should
drive with her knee
man she was all right though yeah shout
out to her sure no I respect it
um this one I don't know if we've ever
talked about this is from Benny b cups
very appropriate ever try to break a
Guinness World Record
that is trashy we know oh uh Katie Nolan
Guinness World Record holder isn't she I
think so we talked about that on the
episode she holds a Guinness World
Record or did huh yeah buttons get on
that so does uh mans I believe didn't
man say yeah Birds boy mans yeah shout
out to John most Donuts stacked in a
tower while blindfolded Katie yes really
seven
what seven get me a blindfold and fully
get your Donuts out of the car
I'm not giving you I'm not giving you my
good donuts for that I'm giving you my
emergency Donuts
those are for emergencies oh bakeries
closed she stacked Donuts blindfolded
yes huh seven yep really I think man's
is like the deepest deepest cold water
died something wild there's there's no
Donuts involved I know that something
really it's like he like freed dove in
Antarctica or something yeah something
wild okay let's talk about indochino
Indochina let's talk about looking fly
and fresh baby Valentine's Day was just
here and gone yeah probably used your
one suit I know I could have used an
indochino suit for the wedding I was
just that I embarrassed myself jammed up
walking around like I was in a bowling
league or something like that gang do
yourself a favor get over to indochino
you got custom made suits Blazers
jackets no tailoring involved you do it
all on the website pick your
measurements they hook it up you're
looking flying fresh in no time yeah
guys they were nice enough to send old
ciparino to tree custom nice shirts feel
like a bajillion dollars walking around
there huh I feel like Sam yam and Jack
Conte walking around there in my Mark
Cuban or somebody you're no Jack
uh every suit is made to your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail create a suit that fits for you
with your style perfectly they offer uh
different Fabrics options for lapel
shape custom Monograms and more the best
part indochino Suits start at just 449
and shirts from 89. uh indochino also
offers completely custom fitted shirts
and Casual Wear get a wardrobe
personalized to your style and taste
without ever spending a fortune uh if
you're ringing in
2023 with Wedding Bells ahead start
planning your custom look with indochino
go to indochino.com use the code garbage
to get 10 off any purchase of 3.99 or
more that's indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code garbage
do it Kippy it's freeze pipe baby you
know what I'm talking about ripped tubes
go get the bangers talking about getting
the based and not coughing up a lung
when you're doing it sure we've all
ripped tubes and caught the cough sure
burned the throat embarrassed yourself
at a party yeah in front of chicks
there's chicks here what are you doing
you look like a bubble Gummer a freeze
pipe you don't gotta worry about that
because it cools the smoke about 300
degrees there yeah keep it in the
freezer top quality break it out when
company shows up or you got a fresh bag
on the way I put it on ice Daddy
gippy's getting lifted I want to talk to
Samson I like my pools on the Rocks I
don't know about you guys yeah yeah
guys the hype is bad I'm high right now
I smoke my heaters out of a freeze pipe
um just pop it in the freezer for an
hour the smoke passes through and it's
so cold it's easy on the lungs to have a
little toky smoke whatever you want to
smoke the hype is real with 4.4 star
rating over 1100 Reviews free freeze
pipe has been trusted by thousands of
Americans for over five years so for
premium smoking experience at everyday
great prices and free shipping visit
thefreeze pipe.com and use code garbage
for 10 off your next order that's the
t-h-e-freeze pipe.com code garbage to
save 10 shop today your lungs and turtle
thank you do it but I do remember I mean
we've uh having that book as a child the
Guinness World Record Book
guys on the motorcycle
trying to find something I could break
in my house you know what I mean like
some sort of not something I can break a
record I could break as an
eight-year-old you know what I mean
there's like giving up on my t-ball
career but I was trying to be famous
watch the most episode of Family Matters
I'll sit here as long as it takes I'm
going for the forehead record
most goldfish eaten in one sitting
kids consume 97 dinner rolls today
good Lord I always thought that was a
process I thought somebody had to come
they do yeah somebody from Guinness has
to be there used to be a show like The
Guinness Book of World Records does
Guinness own that the beer yeah are they
connected I got a yes and no well so for
the listener new guy Luke's in here
editing and I can't have I can't have
two guys off camera to give me two
different answers
it's like a third base coach I don't
know whether to steal or leave
um
uh there used to be a show Guinness Book
of World Records where people come on
and break records on camera I don't
remember that I do or it was part of a
show remember Unsolved Mysteries they
were always like so serious they'd be
like a guy would be there and like you
know somebody be stacking donuts and he
was acting like it was the most
important thing I remember the guy with
the most bees on him it was it was
started by Guinness and then it
separated into different entities into
2001. huh but yeah I mean corporate
buyout huh merger and acquisition my
kind of like I remember the long
fingernail lady oh that was a guy that
was a guy in like Nepal oh and he would
keep it in a black satin bag that thing
probably stunk around breaking those
things out on a date
it was like you know some like sort of
magical thing that he was able to do
that I remember that the two fat guys on
a motorcycle the tall guy was famous
there was a black and white photo of a
tall guy yeah he didn't look healthy the
eye bulge lady she two-timed with
Ripley's Believe It or Not yeah she was
also on a pledge commercial I think a
lot of people can do that though I think
I knew a kid in high school that could
do one of them also to me if anybody in
my family tried to
well not even that like who do you think
you are hold the world record you owe
child support all right they start
bringing up your real personal [__]
small dick fast they're gonna stack
these goddamn Donuts I did as a kid
think uh that that came with unlimited
wealth and clout oh it's nice I thought
you got millions of dollars yeah you're
the tallest guy somebody should be
paying you yeah something uh-huh I find
that it's only like trade shows and
stuff yeah you get like a piece of paper
we'll have to ask Katie what she got for
it I think we probably did probably
nothing it will cash maybe no I don't
think so shout out to Katie Nolan she's
the best she's great uh all right this
one's from TJ have you or anyone in your
family ever been a member of a band's
official fan club which I do they still
exist that much probably not with like
Twitter and
you know Instagram and stuff like that I
don't know we should join one no why I
don't know come on we could be on the
board we get to meet Taylor Swift that
was always looked down upon anybody that
was uh
in the fan club back in the day well
that was also something you had to like
that was the ant that never got married
sure yeah that was something you had to
like fill out a form and send in back in
the day now you could join online sure
that makes sense sure but like back in
the day when like the official fan club
was a thing that was a little kooky yeah
I don't know what you got for it I don't
know yeah we would never uh that was
always like that's how they get you type
thing sure that's how they viewed that
yeah because it's like you don't know
[__] Madonna or whatever yeah it's
not really Steven Tyler that's sending
you that message I'll tell you that all
right let's see this one's from Jordan
ten dollar homie never had one red is it
garbage to go to the bathroom for the
sole purpose of wiping
I remember I saw my dad do that at the
gym one time
just went into the stall to wipe and I
was like whoa let's clean up a little
bit I guess yeah I was having a rough
day yeah I've been there ah yeah yeah
sure a little slippery you have a sixth
sense about those things sure how you
get older that's the kind of stuff that
you do
as a little kid you probably walk around
with doodoo in your pants sure I'm gonna
clean up like a gentleman that's tough
that's why a lot of people do like uh
you know the wipes which I'm not a big
fan of Luke travels with the dude wipes
I went to his bathroom to steal his
toothpaste he did it's all in Florida
not to get into detail but do you follow
up with a dry wipe after you use them
yeah yeah yeah just just those it's like
it's like you're in a pool or something
real slippery
it's not a fan of those yeah I don't
know and I didn't like them back because
like my butts turned on when I do it if
you don't dry at all [__] slipping
off the seat over here I feel like a
[__]
get your ass to church
I'm gonna go to confession after this
thing
kids wide open back yeah I feel too
uh different it only happens after you
have a couple of drinks too
I normally don't do this gets loose as a
caboose
like the baby ones either back in the
day what they smelled like baby sure
sure no good yeah yeah of course
um all right let's see here this is for
MO is it garbage to have someone in your
family get divorced only then to remarry
that same person I've seen this before
I've seen that I have a buddy whose
parents have been married like maybe
four times but you go through to the
point where he was like leave me out of
whatever you're doing I don't care you
go through the whole Pro separation I
understand I know couples that that
still aren't divorced sure just
separated which I like that Arrangement
that's very old school are they together
though like do they still canoodle uh
they they were separated and got back
together and I think they separated
again but yeah the door is still open
but isn't it expensive to go through
that process of divorce
and all that stuff I'm passion though
baby keep coming back for it man I love
you I love you one day I hate you the
next Crazy Love yeah yeah that seems
like it's a
costly and a lot of time but also after
the first one I think it's like yeah
we'll get divorced again maybe we'll get
back like you I feel you're you're more
hesitant you're more ready to pull that
trigger you already got the lawyer's
number I know everything is all in just
do it again bill was I worry about that
with me because I'm I'm 47 now
like my wedding it's gonna be sad isn't
it getting married at like 50 mm-hmm
can't have like a big wedding with that
right maybe it's a little different now
I feel like we have to do it like the
Poconos
or something like that I don't know and
a champagne hot tub yeah because I
remember as a kid
there would be like a second marriage
and I remember being at the wedding like
what this guy's an adult what are we
doing here sure it is weird I guess
because you're older
not get you're older getting married for
the first time which gives me a little
bit of a pass right
I don't know that's what I'm saying it's
a little awesome wedding it's a little
Uncharted Territory though yeah
because how many 40
let's say it happens this year yeah like
like how many 47 year olds are getting
married for the first time is the priest
gonna say you have your whole life in
front of you you gotta but he takes a
little shopping they got about three
years on you
I better I better wrap this up to having
to hold until death does he bark
they're having the hole for the next two
weeks
through sickness and in sickness
all right yeah they're getting they're
getting married in the divorce and
that's yeah that's pretty trash as a
child of uh what's that fourth wedding
like
yeah you can't be doing the whole thing
you can't be expecting gifts from
anybody no I still want cash I think in
my my friends instance it was just very
like
legally yeah they just legally went and
did it again although I'm not opposed to
the separate the married but Separate
Lives I also like that that's a good
look though she lives here he lives
there they're together but they live
Separate Lives that's very that's not
school Hollywood legally it is the guys
at a church well okay
you know but what's the point of that
though just to say my wife I don't know
so that I won't disappoint my mom yeah
maybe she don't give a [__] she gonna
give you away no I'm not saying me to
give me away
better use your dude wipes that night
didn't mean me
give me away comes down smoking a heater
thank God
um
that's funny that's pretty good
all right let's see this is Isaiah oh
Isaac with a K shout out i-s-a-a-k I
ain't never seen that you do lunch a
couple of names every once in a while
well is that dude
i-s-a-a-k-i-s-a-a-k I get halfway
through that I'm thinking it's I what'd
I say Isaiah yeah I could see that and
the K looks like an H yeah come on I'm
flying by this eating my pants I don't
like those spelling things or where
parents can try to get creative with the
spelling Isaac is
here we go AC should be Isaac right
unless you want to use the traditional
Hebrew spelling which is i-s-a-a-k yeah
oh is it really all right he went to
tribe fair enough old school he's a
Chosen One my man
I'm not going to question the
authorities
can't fight City Hall you know what I
mean I'm gonna tell you do it that's how
you do it uh C
yeah I don't know I guess that is the
only Isaac I know is Isaac Hayes too
yeah I don't think he's spelling it up
shout out to Isaac Hayes uh is it
garbage to have to hold the TV antenna
in place for the entire Super Bowl game
including commercials because your
family doesn't have cable so you have to
watch the game through a mirror
what through a mirror man this guy they
are biblical these this that's crazy
dude if you still got an antenna I don't
even think are they still broadcasting
that this has to be as a kid I assume uh
do they still broadcast the TV like that
with an antenna I think yes but no
remember they went back to you had to go
they were selling that they were Hawking
that box for a while the federal
government yes because they couldn't use
the antenna they didn't use the rabbit
ears anymore so this had to be as a kid
you can get a digital antenna I think
yeah so no one's using rabbit that just
sounds like it gives you cancer I don't
trust that at all
yeah dude I don't think anybody's using
an antenna anymore right uh no my
landlord told me to get one my old my
old Greek landlord was like you need an
antenna getting antenna you get like 17
channels I swear no money plus it helps
you get into the neighbor's house
pick the Lockwood I saw it through his
window he was watching like Bulgarian
soccer and really yeah got money on a
game
get himself a new TV if it comes through
yikes yeah I know he's Pakistan cooking
show that's got to be as a kid and I can
say yes 100 I have stood there because I
was the youngest so I had to stand there
and hold it and watch it from the side
not the Super Bowl to our cousins for
something good actual learned people
with cable
uh yeah we are we you know we still
don't have cable upstairs in my mom's
house so TVs are but for the longest
time we had one with rabbit ears that we
would move from room to room uh you know
if my brother wanted her I wanted it or
whatever uh yeah that's but then
everybody I do remember that digital
converter box
there's also it was a big deal it was
like the it was like the real ID of the
uh 2000s what what because I have a this
just pops on my head I have a
what would it take back in the day for
you guys to get a new TV
a lot oh you know it was a it's so much
that I think it only happened
I mean the TV that we have downstairs
by the by the wood burning stove we
bought that that's pre-911 that TV
and what's crazy is that he we can
somehow because we have the the here's
the the cable down there
but we he can get Netflix on it so it
has like the app section in it that's
impossible pre-911. I'm telling you I
don't it might it might be through the
cable box though that's how it might
work that makes more sense because
you've got some sort of fire stick on it
or something you use the cable there's
no way a table a TV from 2001 has
Netflix on it was Netflix even around
even the the mailbox Netflix I think it
was just starting to creep around yeah
it was just starting to that was mailbox
Netflix was still like 2009. so it has
it has it has the it has the cable box
at one point you guys at the head of
Technology what's going on 1997. Netflix
started yeah wow so listen what year did
digital Netflix dude there's what year
did Smart TVs come out
there's no this is a smart TV
I'm telling you but then I I understand
about it okay I might be wrong dude it
had to be it had to be 2001. cell phones
2007.
you're telling me seven the the Foley
family I'm Googling you're freaking me
out the Foley family had a smart TV
seven years before they were invented
that's what you're telling me finding
this out right now
good morning hey tuts what are you doing
hey Patty Hey Kevin how are you darling
I'm good all right enough for the Chit
Chat you're on the air I have a quick
question for you the Panasonic TV wait a
minute wait a minute I saw Kevin on the
beach he looked very relaxed and
comfortable you're looking good you win
the misses thank you Patty he spent
eight grand on a dinner mom half of that
could have been yours listen I have a
quick question for you the Panasonic TV
that's downstairs
yeah what year did you buy that
oh God I don't know Joe Elmo and your
brother hooked it up I went over to Best
Buy and bought it I the 90s maybe the
90s so how does it have Netflix on it
well then maybe sometime in the 2000s
ask your brother it was definitely
before 2007 right
oh God yes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right Andrew got one all right let's
start blabbing we're on the air here I
love you I'll talk to you in a little
bit see you Patty Mike what was my
question I just asked you dummy oh okay
all right I love it
all right quit buttering up the boss
here
she's a good kid she's got the hots for
me I think I think what it is is so we
have the cable remote
and has the voice activated I can say
Netflix into it and it comes up so maybe
it's something through that okay but I'm
telling you she definitely bought that
TV I'm not it's a [__] Panasonic for
God's sakes I'm sure are they still in
business we're filming on Panasonic
cameras really
are these pre-911s
go USA that's an American company isn't
it no Panasonic I thought that was
American
I think of a Zenith yeah maybe he's an
RCA
right not gonna knock it not gonna work
here anymore
yeah Cleo you stayed away from
Mitsubishi I'll tell you that Nah if you
can do it if you can do a cool car and a
TV I'm out yeah my dad was never about
that okay let's talk about bespoke post
Oh you mean cool guy stuff for cool
dudes yeah it's called box awesome you
ever heard of it yeah I heard of it I'm
a subscriber and I get it and don't
share with you well that's awesome so am
I I get cool guy stuff too gang do
yourself a favor get over to that uh
bespoke post pick yourself up a box of
awesome it's got fantastic stuff here's
the turkey too what's that they partner
with small businesses top quality stuff
small business spread around a little
bit not like those big sharks out there
yeah do yourself a favor support local
businesses and support people that
support the podcast yeah just take the
quiz at box of awesome.com they'll pick
the right box for you you only pay a
fraction of the cost of what these boxes
are worth plus like the big man said
every 90 of everything from your boxes
from a small up and coming brand and
they got the cocktail kits right
that's how I I do my nice I do a nice
white claw I smoke it for a little bit
give it a real Oaky taste uh it's free
to sign up you can skip a month okay
uh I get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code garbage and check out
that's boxed of also.com code garbage
for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code garbage do it now back
to that gosh darn show back to the show
I thought Panasonic was an American
company ah they're from Japan my dude
really isn't it a Sony is it under Sony
maybe or no no no no direct competitor
okay yeah I saw a guy with a Panasonic
bicycle the other day I was like they
were that used to be big I think
Panasonic bicycles what I remember that
from like these we gotta diversify here
get into something
you start making TVs
Luke get on that way you're sitting
there doing nothing I love how Patty was
like we got that in 1923 actually
then she starts dropping names
his broad she's screwable she also
answered that a half a second after you
hit send she was waiting for somebody
she's like you outside having heaters
waiting for someone to call
yeah
I do like it that's that's she's my Chit
Chat gal I know I get on the phone with
her we start yapping sure like two
broads at a barber shop I love it
um because I remember we had that big
wooden
TV like the TV was wooden I remember my
cousins broke one of those you know what
I mean flat the first flat screen no
this wasn't flat screen no Oh you mean
what one of those yeah you were you
remember buying one of those I know I
don't buy no we had it we're not a big
Tech family I don't know if you've
picked up because those were real old
school the TV in the wooden thing yeah
TV in the wooden box and it sat on top
of like a wooden base yeah those weighed
about 8 000 pounds I remember I could
still smell that still smell the tubes
smell the ozone
dude and you would turn it that'll come
up on an MRI yikes and Rusty this is
looking nice is crazy Rusty on my dog
peed all over the front of it
like multiple times I guess like that
was his spot he died from a brain tumor
six weeks later to the point where the
wood on the front of the base was warped
and we replaced the wood we didn't get a
new TV we reap I set that replaced the
wood with a like a tea like got a two by
four stained it to like kind of match
kind of but it was off you could tell
right away it was oh wait it was bad
yeah no looking back I'm like that was
and then my brother-in-law
by now brother-in-law came over this was
this lasted too long and he was like
what is
this like this is crazy
and he gave us his old TV
is you dating your sister yeah he would
have been like what are these yokels
doing they got a PTV over here he's a
teenager no he was I mean this was like
read like this is of modern era of my
family he was he's dating my sister yeah
because they were in college I was in
high school I don't know yeah they're
bad with the TVs and it's in a big room
and the one they got now is like it's
like a 32 incher you walk in it looks
like a hospital we had a proper
entertainment center with the the okay
remember the Sony TVs they were black
they were still deep and they were heavy
but it was like kind of new it wasn't a
flat screen no those pan I remember
those pan where they were Panasonic the
silver ones right they were still at the
big back but they were silver those flat
screens yeah no we never we skipped that
yeah we missed that we had the old
I mean it's not old but it was like you
know late 90s early 2000s the black
Sony's that had the deep and they had
the they still had the bubble kind of
that was in an entertainment center with
a stereo that wasn't hooked up that just
had speaker wire running throughout the
house we had that until
I don't know I want to say 10 15 years
ago it was the downstairs that got that
got the hook up that got that Panasonic
and that thing's still going strong
shout out to American engineering
shout out to American Japanese
engineering thank God my father died not
knowing that I thought he was a fine
American I think so just tell them it's
made in the USA he'll pay extra for it
but he would he would he would have
hadn't known that because he had a
Panasonic reel-to-reel machine that he
got in uh that he got in Vietnam I was
like his prized possession I think my
mom threw it out got it in Vietnam what
else do you need to know yeah that's
what I'm saying he would have known I'm
surprised he did that so he thought I
mean in your world you thought he
thought he was buying an American
product in Vietnam because I remember
thinking to myself Panasonic is shitty
why didn't you get like a [__] uh
Sony or something like that and I assume
the reason that he got the Panasonic is
he thought it was just stood up and
saluted the flag
absolutely I didn't fight for this
country salute to TV every morning
but yeah man there's Netflix on it it's
got to be through the cable that's yeah
something you got some sort of a day or
your times are off I mean you just heard
her I don't she said it was before 2006
she also said I look good at the beach
and I don't know how she saw that is she
on Instagram
she's all over the place
she snoops around a couple burners they
got a couple finstas yeah okay she don't
know what's going on
um all right let's see here this is from
Jimbo slice ten dollar loan shark
respect that there you go uh did your
mom have you light her seeks for her
when you were a kid broad had me
cranking heaters at seven why a light
may be driving that's maybe like I'm
driving light me a cig nah that's real
garbage it makes me feel fancy yeah I
got a sick boy that it had to be while
driving I never liked that though what
for as gross as I am I never liked
Sharon sigs the the wetness oh no I
would never want somebody to like that
for me and then take it
gross me out no I
I'm trying to think of like when Mike I
would hand them I would handle I'd maybe
maybe my aunt would let me light hers
every once in a while but in her mouth
not me giving it to her like a man of
the night oh that's what I was thinking
yeah no he said she had me cranking
heaters I think he would light them for
me I was thinking he was like a
bartender
the old man breaking your Stones huh
through the one hand over top I'd say
you know you're getting laid you do that
when's the last time you little lady
cigarette
probably my wife when she smoked huh I
did it not that long ago somebody asked
me for a smoke and then I I lit it for
them yeah he's a homeless guy but yeah I
don't like that no no usually I'd keep
the lighter oh yeah yeah I got I got six
on me keep them keep them I don't like
yeah that's crazy that's not lighting
smokes for your what the [__] I think my
dad obviously found out
but we still didn't really smoke all the
kids and cousins of my generation
it was always hidden it was always it
still is they still like at a wedding
it's like me and they're like hey you
guys you know what I mean yeah
um everything was always hidden I was
always the one jumping on the grenade
everybody was drinking
everybody was smoking but it was always
hidden
crazy and it was Irish yeah it's a lot
of our you know not only people know in
their business I know that is what I
don't want anybody doing I'm drunk
uh-huh don't let anybody know I'm drunk
or having heaters it's a little bit
funner though to be honest with you what
that's what no I mean the booze in our
families out I mean that's out and about
unless you got a problem then you hide
it this is like a real problem then you
know you get on the radar when people
are having afternoon coffees
there's a couple members of my family
you see walking around with a Wawa cup
afternoon
all right
I'm talking heavy bike
vodka what a splash of having him
yeah that's um all right uh this one's
from Lewis 20 Homie first time asking is
it garbage to take your shoes off in a
movie theater
yeah I kind of get it though if it's not
crowded
I can kinda get it yeah it's trash the
thing that keeps me from doing that is
pure fear because so I'm grabbing your
Piggies there's mice and rats in movie
theaters all that candy everywhere it's
true they're everywhere a lot of candy
yeah I remember in the 90s being in a
couple of movie theaters over there in
Montgomery County and they're like
seeing mice and stuff like that nah
never take my shoes off there I didn't
think of that that makes sense Mouse
running on your piggies new thank you oh
man a heavy bike Lizard jumped out of
the [__] bushes the other day when I
was down on vacation I was gonna say
weird
Washington Heights
stay out of the Bronx huh yeah and I
thought he was coming in the pool and
what how heavy bike like a little
salamander like a lizard Komodo not that
enough to
how big that big bigger with tail bigger
what the [__] what kind of Hotel were
you staying at it was probably like fro
but it was thick it was like a oh I
would have freaked dude I would have
left this thing jumped off like out of a
bush onto like down a ledge onto the
side of the pool dude and I was
paralyzed
dude they have claws on him too did you
ever see that video the one swimming in
the pool that's what I picture those are
real scary that's a certain kind of
lizard and you know you can't move quick
in a pool not against that it's like
playing against LeBron are you kidding
me they could break your ankles in two
seconds I like the little salamanders
the ones that we saw down down in
Florida they're still unpredictable I
think they're cute and they can't really
bite you and I think it's cool because
it gets a daddy
comes back with The Mamas and the Papas
your head
but they look they look like little baby
dinosaurs and I like that I think it's
cute but at a certain point anything
bigger than that now you think bigger
than an action figure I'm out this thing
was like Jefferson they're too
prehistoric man that's a goddamn
dinosaur
this thing look at the thing that got
Newman and Jurassic Park
easy big fell this thing opened up and
just hit and spit at me that's the way I
felt in Hawaii driving around the big
island in that jeep that's very it was
pouring rain too you got a candy shaving
cream
the entire time I swear to God's exact
scene I was driving down the darkest
Road ever in a Jeep and it was pouring
rain the entire time we were talking
about Hawaii on hard feelings I I
pictured you as Newman Jurassic Park man
it's no there's no street lights
crazy
um
uh uh let's all right this one's from
Jeremy There's a garbage used Ikea bags
at suitcases took a weekend trip up to
northern PA and saw a family loading
their van for vacation the whole family
was using Ikea back not in the car I
don't think I don't I'm taking that to
an airport
is a little Trash here's my thing I also
checked two duffel bags
and one was filled with Trader Joe's
snacks oh my God they don't have them
over there
yeah I checked two duffel bags where's
your luggage you have every time we we
travel
minimum once a month I meet you at an
airport every time you have a you have
different luggage every single time you
have different luggage
uh what's going on and it's never new
it's never like hey I got a new suitcase
you always have old luggage I gotta keep
those airport dogs
keep them guessing
hey fully why does your bag smell like
coffee yeah
what are you doing what's your go-to
right now I have one Ikea bag
those reusable bags though man that's
what you're supposed to do with the Ikea
bag this here's my thing I'm a big thank
you all the Ikea bags in here are mine
you know who's starting to skimp a lot
that was the fastest you've ever Shook
and Kippy off your tail well I mean like
blowing a light in Chinatown baby
[Laughter]
I well like I
I know how to negotiate and if he isn't
giving anything up you go all right
there's it's we're gonna enter we're
either gonna rent a real deal I had that
bag I had that thing with me it's just I
had where were we just brought that huge
suitcase and we were laughing at the
size of a silver suitcase that was old
when was this what silver suitcase
the one that I just brought I don't
remember yeah I had that I had that old
one the one we were making we had one
not too long ago that we were making fun
of you for I think we threw that out I
have a nice roller now but it's broke so
it's not nice
see this is what I'm talking about I
gotta get into it you only live in the
reality he of the facts he gives you the
duffel bag I need it because I had shoes
and stuff for the wedding that I had to
go to yeah shoes don't fit in regular
suitcases not in mine dude those
t-shirts take up a lot of room dude
it's like flying with parachutes it is
man
they're huge sure plus I had a pair of
pants
crazy
you had to send those FedEx these five
they're heavy too yeah they don't fit
uh-huh okay
all right I think the Ikea back to the
back the original point I think in the
car I think it's okay in the car if
you're going to your Mountain House your
Shore House sure an aunt's house a
cousin's house checking in with one of
those things at an airport or a tough
well yeah sure but you don't bring that
into the lobby with you you park if
you're driving you park you go in there
like a gentleman with your briefcase and
then when they give you the key you go
out then you bring sure you wait until
then you wait until Nightfall to sneak
in the bodies
and the other four relatives that you
got with you but you know who's skimping
on that stuff to and first of all
I don't mind paying a dollar or whatever
for those but let's go Target they give
you the shittiest smallest bags
they really cut back on us they're not
they could be bigger they're decent
quality Ikea doesn't screw around
they're made out of tarp too yeah you
put anything in there
carry rocks in that thing they're all
right shirts yeah they're all right I
like those Ikea bags yeah I've been
shopping a lot at Target recently they
the worst bags ever I like them now
they're all right but she can never find
them and all that stuff what they're
never right there you gotta ask somebody
you do the self-checkout you don't do a
soft check I did a self checkout there
right there every time I go oh the wrong
one I guess dude don't want to they open
up like that there's the ones in New
York that aren't proper targets they're
like mini targets I hate that oh God
it's like a knife fight in those places
I hate it everything's locked up yeah
travel size deodorant locked up at my
target what are we doing I hate that
can't we let can't that be stolen
they're my favorite videos when the
employees
stand up to the dudes doing that sure
when they come in with like a trash bag
and take all the stuff and they they
gang tackle them at the door oh I love
that what is that one they're like some
old lady pushes like what are you doing
yeah because they're that they're the
reason that that all that stuff's locked
up sure
[__] is there that much of a market
for that are you buying Street deodorant
Jesus I don't know I only buy
American-made Panasonic deodorant
sell drugs man what are we doing yeah
um all right let's see I think we have
time for a couple of more here
um this one's from Gucci Mane
shout out to coochie man that's all
right uh is the garbage at your family's
preferred method of fishing is using a
product called the chilling reel for
context it's a beer koozie with a reel
attached to it which I have seen on
Shark Tank and I think they did get a
deal how do you cast with that it's like
a little it's like imagine holding like
a mug or whatever and then there's just
like a little spool here so I don't know
you snap it out beer spill I don't know
spear bill I don't know it's like beer I
guess you passed and then put it in okay
so then you it's so you can hold and
reel at the same time it feels like
that'd be messy I think the idea is that
it's not messy I think I think
negotiating a fishing rod if I remember
the pitch correctly a fishing rod and a
beer at the same time is hard it's a
beer koozie that you can catch fish with
it's probably the greatest product I've
ever seen it seems like a good time I
can't see Mr Wonderful going in on that
no I think Damon did because he's a fit
he's a he's like a fisherman
also Gucci Mane sounds like a great guy
you know what he probably knows a good
time you know what I like on that show
Lori
and yeah something else set a gazangas
the money's classy uh yeah all right you
know who's uh and Mr Wonderful Mr
Wonderful's all right I like that Robert
Herjavec is the guy in the end
sharp the guy sharp guy dude Sharp
Dressed well-dressed
Yugoslavian I think he was I'm going Mr
Wonderful I think really yeah kind of a
prick I like that hard knows I was
friends
I'll plug the patreon Cuban I think it'd
be all about him
yeah I mean I think it's tough to be
able to use the jeans will you I think
it's time to be a business meeting here
uh I think all billionaires are pretty
much all about them I would assume sure
if you're just the you're the coolest
dude amongst cool dude like you're the
most important guy among important
people if you were a billionaire would
you would you would you go more uh Mr
Wonderful sharp suit or would you go the
Cuban route with the the jeans and the
in the Blazer I don't even think I would
go that
he's naked I would just rock whatever
I'm rocking I would just spit on
millionaires yeah nicer versions of what
I I'd get it just maybe cooler black
t-shirts
a cooler pair of Nikes you were in
Target no this is uh
classic true classic
sure yes that's exactly who it is maybe
this week maybe it's not I'm not sure
all right this one's from Alec uh ten
dollar homie never have one red taking
your kids with you regularly while
working Uber Eats or something similar
garbage or not I mean do what you got to
do you're hemmed up you're hemmed up
yeah I had to go to work a lot with my
parents me too I remember sitting in a
doctor's office with my mom being like I
this is weird that I'm in here I'd be
looking at microscope and [__] man uh my
mom was a manager at uh the Gap at the
Wyoming Valley Mall
and in the summer I would say that my
brother and I went to work with her more
often than not yeah you got to yeah
I tell you what as a little kid
it wasn't that bad it was a pretty sweet
Mall
all right yeah the mall all day is a kid
they had a Super Pretzel soft pretzel
next next to them or some kind of chop
that had that and a picture with a photo
with your face on it it's a no more free
samples yeah well I remember I didn't
know how to add uh ad yes at the time
and I'd stolen money out of my mom's
purse
and I went over there it's all making
sense and I think I had 10 pennies and I
thought the pennies were dimes
and I didn't have enough to get a
pretzel and she shoot the lady shooed me
away because it was the first time that
was the first day I ate pennies
because it was very similar to the Taco
Bell the Taco Bell thing or the uh the
Wendy's thing with the cheese fries this
was the first time that I knew
couple weeks ago I told you that the
first time I had cheese fries was at a
Wendy's and they wasn't on the menu they
just knew a guy they had the cheese
sauce or the potato and somebody showed
me that you can dip it
this was the first time I came across
that people were dunking their soft
pretzels and cheese because they had the
little cups of cheese and you remember
the super soft pretzel case they'd have
a couple cups of cheese in there yeah I
know that's what I was trying to get my
hands on but I didn't have enough dip my
wiener and cheese if they let me I would
love to see your list of like man's
greatest achievement like the hydrant
collider you know landing on the moon
cheese for your pretzels uh-huh I'd say
it's up there I mean it changed my life
I should say the icy thing that spins
around is pretty sweet too let you know
it's in the store
[Applause]
they go for top billing you can see that
in Sporting Goods or housewares you know
where it is you know where to find me
just trying I'm just trying to somehow
navigate my way over to that so I can
throw a tantrum get my hands on a cherry
I see yeah like a gentleman huh
uh all right let's do this then we gotta
wrap her up this is from JJ it's a
garbage sorry
is it garbage to only set your microwave
cook time using add 30 seconds
why key in three minutes when you can
just hit that sucker six times
that's crazy really that's all I operate
wait what do you mean so you're putting
something in there for two and you're
gonna stand it like a [__] what do
you mean I don't think I understand the
question okay so a lot of like by
growing up we had easy minute where you
just press one button easy minute and
that starts it for one minute yes and
then I would if it was if it called for
two three minutes you just hit that two
or three times this guy's got an ad 30
seconds button oh so he just presses
that six times so he's not waiting until
it doesn't go 30 seconds stops you gotta
hit it again
and he's out the door totally cool with
that but I thought of that I thought
every button represented a minute I
think if you hit the three three minutes
come up
no because a lot of them you have to
enter time a lot of them you'll have to
go like set time
no but I thought they all had
easy buttons and it wasn't just one
minute it was if you hit the two it was
two minutes the three was three minutes
I'm pretty sure we always rocked like
that except for the first one we had I
don't know that wasn't like 87. I was
real old that was a huge deal it was the
size of our kitchen my dad got it for my
mom for Christmas it was the biggest
deal ever
the whole neighborhood came over to see
this thing yeah it was wild that's uh we
always had the we had a KitchenAid one
because when we moved to that house it
was like a new house and that was like
my Mom's Kitchen
but then we kept that up until
we kept that for 30 years probably crazy
and then just got a new one see that
American engineering right there I don't
know who we have now Panasonic maybe I
don't know who it is we gotta wrap it up
though dang we love you to death come
see us on the road the dates are up the
shows are selling out so do yourself a
favor grab those texts and we'll see you
next week peace